[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you thank you for thank you for
the time thank you for being here
uh so we work together at j ventures
um it is so much fun and i'm learning so
much every single day
um and i'm excited to be part of this
amazing group that you
that you that you started but before we
get to that i want to
learn a little bit about you and how you
even got to this thing called
j angels and j ventures i want to go
back to the time where you're a reporter
and you're a journalist what is it like
what do you cover
what it what what are you excited about
so first mikhail we also learn from you
so it goes to
both ways um
i started my career after my army
service i was uh
i was at the israeli idf spokesperson
unit and
naturally after that i went for the
media i had a pr agency
and i just uh finished my service and
then
um and then i wanted to change jerusalem
my jerusalem where i grew up many people
in my generation left the city and the
only way to convince them that there's
something in the city that is beyond the
political issues and beyond religion
is about economy so i
i went to the local newspaper
that had about 60 000 circulation and
asked them
to start the economy section
at the beginning they were laughing
because jerusalem wasn't known for the
economy
but then it made a lot of sense for
everybody so uh
we created an economy section with
another friend from
my army service i was 23 at the time
um we had about 30 percent
higher circulation because of that and
we kept a lot of people in jerusalem
but after three years of of uh writing
and editing this section
which had 64 pages 12 journalists in
that time
by the way the best journalist that they
ever worked with cite casual that is
very known in the us
um noah yadlin which is a famous
um book writer
we i decided to move to tel aviv the the
thing was it didn't work
went into a deeper hole than i predicted
and i didn't want to be the last one to
shut
the light yeah and instead i moved to
tel aviv enjoyed the
alex which was a daily newspaper in
israel to the
section and my natural thing i always
liked gadgets and things like that so
they asked me what i want to do and i
started writing about tech and i did it
for
six years i became the editor of the
tech section
been with 99 2000 and all the roller
coaster
wow i've seen thousands of companies
thousands of uh deals many vcs
in my understanding very early on
because i had competition
because it would be very hard for me to
compete with people who are covering
this
in this a long time yeah so i thought
okay who are the people that you don't
need to know many people but they
they know a lot of people how do you wh
what's your gateways
and i thought that the vcs should be my
gateways because one vc
knows 20 30 companies that in his
own portfolio but he also sees trans
around him
so i started talking with the vcs and i
fast on later i i became the
you know the most powerful journalist in
israel because i knew everything
yeah and i didn't want to publish
everything by the way
because we we got into the same
situation that we're coming now when
there
there would be less fundraising and more
more layoffs and i had three
three things that i always consistently
kept one is
i never wrote about the deal that never
happened so i told the company listen i
know you're
going to be acquired but if i will write
about it you will probably
will ruin your your deal let's do it
that way
before you do the pr when you finish
give me
one day six hours give me the biggest
story i don't want to ruin for you
give me the story the second thing
was staying staying a person
um so i never wrote about the company
that is laying off before
the company told the the employees i i
didn't think they should learn about it
from the newspaper
and in that way i found my what because
um why do you care so much i don't know
i it sounds i mean from a bystander's
perspective
journalists and reporters sometimes
rating comes above all and getting the
scoop
yeah because the company might not
succeed because of this or
you know yeah people's feelings might
get hurt but you know it's journalism
and if it gets if it gets readers
attention then it's worthy
but but you have a different idea in a
different perspective
that's why i thought that nobody
remembers the scoops so another company
is
laid off you remember who wrote it
nobody remembers who wrote it so it's
really insignificant if you will
lose another scoop but you will save
people's feeling
and it's much more important um and it
the karma came back to me um
my father-in-law was the ceo of the
company
that i knew him for my work and he shut
down his company
and i had all the i verified this with
the board
i called him i didn't know he would be
my father
he was he was a ceo of a company in
israel
um and i called him and i told him
listen
uh all the other newspapers knows about
any other things that they write five
days later i have five
five days ahead of me before they start
to know what what i'm writing
so i'm not going to write anything in
the next five days and then you will
but but in five days i'm going to
publish it so you have five days
to decide what you want to do it was
enough for him to
to do what he needed to do and i did it
with all the companies
three months later and with my um
girlfriend at the time that i just met
i didn't even know her last name
and she asked me you know
who's my father said who's your father
said
and she said the name i said one second
and then he said i grew up in in the
in the us he didn't read hebrew he said
what did you write
and i said oh no one second so this
story is
that you know if if you're a good person
at the end it will come back to you if
there would be just another journalist
who doesn't care
then probably i wouldn't get this
beautiful and amazing wife that i have
so
i told this story to many of the
journalists that uh replaced me
afterwards
i had no idea how dead this is beautiful
yeah and it helps it's helped so so that
was my
my uh values at the time my publisher
always said that i
published only four percent of what i
know and i found it interesting and then
but then in 2004 um
we created a new um magazine called the
market a printed magazine i was in the
um a strategic thinking of how to create
a newspaper and to create it
but this the same time i had a lot of
offers to leave the newspaper to the pc
world
and my publisher at that time in my
editor guy who only convinced me to stay
and he said you can change something
that didn't change for 84 years so i
decided to do that
but i also told him listen you don't let
me
invest in stock exchange i already have
apartments
i want to have a startup second time in
my career
someone who is my publisher or my editor
is laughing so he was laughing and then
said
how can you create a startup when you
are the editor of the high-tech section
here in
red and which was another newspaper that
we covered yeah
and i said you know what you know that's
the best way to learn
and he said okay in two conditions you
can have your startup without using your
original name your your the name that
you you were born with
yeah and without raising money from out
of because
then you're leveraging your your
positions right
you're not averaging your position it's
fine right
and so um
i changed my my my original plans and
and started with a childhood friend a
startup called zealot for you which was
it i thought you were about to say that
i changed my original name but okay
yeah i i called myself ron levine um
which is uh our family my my my four
names is
oh they're money living this is my my
former name but i usually use
all the data money and we started the
startup
that was like care.com for maids and
babysitters and everything
working with home we did in israel a bit
uk um we didn't raise money we put uh
fifteen hundred dollars each one of us
and we sold it after 18 months to yellow
pages
uh touchwood we did the money and
um the problem was i was still in my
position when we had
the dialogue and they didn't know
anything about my
my day job they didn't know this is what
that morning that they read about
um and i had to leave were you a
full-time journalist back then yeah i
was full-time journalist i was full-time
editor of two sections kept an internet
and the high-tech section of our arts
and market
and they did it at night and it was
quite the first month
um and we sold it and then
i had to resign after that i decided to
leave and they were the first article
about
me about the the website and the the
startup was that
the market they wrote about finally
people
and they called me after that was was
that you
yeah so and then i turned to be a vc so
that was my
my fast track into to become a starter
piece it was very very fast
and my my conclusion by the way that is
relevant also for today's
um situation is i didn't come from the
high tech i was a journalist i was
covering the tech
but when i was thinking about moving to
the decathl
i don't have the expertise so what i'm
coming with
and the concept of having a startup i
said listen
if i'm if this is a you know a
successful startup
then i was successful entrepreneur right
it
wouldn't work i was experienced
entrepreneur
in any case i became a ceo i became a
you know a vp a business of the company
i gained all the right lines on my
resume
and my experience in doing it without
any paying for any school or any
you know i started automatically from
the top and i think this is always a
good tip for
anything anyone who thinks about how to
start his career
looking at the glass ceiling how far it
will take and how long it is
sometimes you can do bypass and the
bypass if you just take bold movement
and
what i risk every hours and a risk
fifteen hundred
dollars that's what i risk that's it
wow okay so i'm gonna so so you're in
rhodium
and i want to move now quickly to to j
angels and j
ventures because uh because we don't
have much time and
i i have to get to understand how your
your mind thinks
around the community so you're taking
this notion of a venture capital firm
a fund a proper fund that operates like
a fund
but you're saying hold on this is not
just about the money it's not just about
the how we the companies who invest it's
also about
our community as investors and about our
relationship with each other
and how we can help each other so tell
me what is what is this fund
that i'm also very lucky to be a part of
and and how did you even come to
to create it so i'll just go back a bit
um i've been since 2005 i've been doing
vc investments
yeah in israel and u.s i took a two
years
um reserve duty to build the israeli
high-tech industry association the iati
and that and to take it from the israeli
venture capital association into
something broader
so my my belief and i worked with your
father though
it was amazing is how to create things
that are beyond
just i i believe very much in the
ecosystem i really believe in building
things
i was one of the founding members of
icon of intro and others
because of the same logic and and in the
past years when i was
a partner at rhodium that was a very
successful uh
private you know single lp fund
i wanted to continue doing things that
are not in the mainstream
so rhodium had a very unique position
because we invested
a single lp in money yep and we had the
patience and this is why we had
good returns in j ventures jay angel's
my
first philosophy was how to connect to
communities who are very separate
israeli and the jewish born americans in
the us
i was very concerned about there's no
connection between them
and none of the other verticals wanted
to do something about it so i said okay
if we as long as we bring people to our
people and very high level
we create something that have the same
incentive so
if i would tell people hey let's build
the community and say hey hold it i'm
very very busy
but if you tell them you come and you
meet the best people
in syria best investors the best people
the best ceos the best
and you will see the best deal flow in
silicon valley then they say where do i
sign in
once they pass the door they become a
community and this is what happened to
us so we became a community
and very early on and we didn't take
money jim
jimmy carson
amazing person and he was on the board
of levi's
of in in other launch media and others
and he invested in sequoia and iconic
and other
plants but when we talked about it how
do you build this community
it's further it is not patronizing you
don't want to waste your time with
someone
that you don't feel that is in the same
level you want to fill the
room with people in the same level as
you so we were very picky about the
people we
we bought here yeah then we start to see
that we have very good deal flow
and and early on in 2017 we created an
investment committee
we had partners from bessemer sequoia
lightspeed
current or former investors so we were
very strong as an angel group we had a
screening committee with a lot of vcs in
a lot of levels and a lot of serial
founders those are the three
parts that you know then uh
in 2018 we decided to have a small fund
because we just saw a very good deal and
we already had exits so people came to
me and said let's have fun
and i said guys i don't want to manage
money of others because i'm a full-time
partner in a different place
but i said okay if you want to do it
let's do something else let's do a
kibbutz
that's where capitalism was everybody
puts a
small amount of money let's feel that we
are all
equal so no one we have billionaires in
our group
they can't invest 10 million and someone
invests 10
000. everybody's in the same range
and what we wanted to check is first
is those this community where we had 84
lps if they share the the deal flow if
they help the companies
if they are engaged and after a year we
had 50
of our lps engaged in screening sourcing
for helping companies and i'm talking
and you know the people there it's
really top of the line people we are
about but i have to say i have to go
back and say
you know when you're a journalist you
told
you gave those five days and you said
i'm i'm gonna put
the people before the story before the
rating and you know
i walk into a room and you're right
there's billionaires there and there's
people
and that i know want to be more active
because they believe in the fun
so much that they want to put more in
and you're saying no no no we're
community first
we're equal first eve and you know
most vcs you offer them money especially
when they're raising
they want the money and and it and it's
different and i think also that's what
gets me excited and i have to also share
my experience coming into this
arena and we're sitting in a big room
with about 80
90 lps sitting there and you
and you go one by one i'm like i know
him from that article and i know
and he founded this company and she
wrote that book and she's a partner in
that firm
and and it's such a humbling experience
to see everybody so engaged for so much
time
um and and it's really really special
thanks no it's really what we try to
achieve so we
we also said no to people because we
didn't feel that this is
you need to have your ego outside of the
room you need to be in a situation
where well you don't feel the room with
your ego and those people are very
successful but they they are humble
enough to know
that when they pass this this this door
they become a community yeah the
responsibilities for the community if
someone told me one of our vc
investors who is uh did 46 exits and saw
the company for one billion so
he said all right every time i'm there i
don't have
the feeling you know i don't have to
fight with any partner i'm just
there's always someone who's asked a
better question and i would ask and i
wanted to ask that question and i don't
feel that he
stole it from me i feel honored that
he's smarter than i
am i love it one of them i
unbelieve and the fact that you haven't
all practically in every industry you
have
experts and it's such a because it's
agnostic and it's you know
every person that comes to present and
and you just see the room and
every person that comes in with a
different set and and when you piece
that when you put the puzzle together
it creates something really really uh
wonderful um
oh that before we go i have to i will
explain to you that just the last part
of j
ventures because this is where we are
now and you will cut after and edit
whatever you need
no editing anything this is beautiful
so so j ventures is a is the next step
of what we decided to do so we started
to raise a bigger fund but
the concept remains the same so people
put a bit more money
in the fund yeah so this is uh more like
the 20 30 40 minute of fun
um it was easy for us to reviews for 160
people in
in five months 160 people
but it's the individuals we said no to
vc's who wanted to invest so we have
bc funds who asked the partnership to
invest in us
but what is unique about it is that we
said okay
we are in silicon valley but silicon
valley is not a market
for most of the companies that we see is
not a market and when there will be a
correction and this was in november
december when we started
before there will be a correction and we
said in correction days
you need to go outside of silicon valley
and the most insignificant thing for a
company would be go to market
how fast they go to the market so our
philosophy was okay
what's going on in new york what's going
on in detroit did what is what about you
and dallas in in texas is energy
and la's entertainment you don't have
any other center of entertainment
the movie industry and boston is cyber
and med tech and same is um
so when you look at those communities we
have now
the former cfo ford in detroit
we have people from wall street in new
york and advertising in europe we have
people from the movie industries
in l.a now when you're the next netflix
might come from silicon valley but it
might come
from l.a so if it comes from silicon
valley we want to open the doors for
them
in la and if it comes in automotive in
silicon valley in detroit they forgot
already what we didn't learn yet
in silicon valley so this hybrid of
engaged communities from all over we
have in london we are in singapore we
are in tel aviv of course
which is a very important part for of
our group
and what we see is that we invest we
don't invest only in israelis or jewish
we're investing everything
we're investing in just good good
entrepreneurs regardless where they come
from
most of them are in silicon valley we
have a very big
theater of israeli expects that are in
the u.s but beyond that we see just
lots of amazing companies coming we just
invested in a company for boston
we invested with costler ventures we
invested in it in a company in l.a
so the fact that we see deal flow coming
from all those places but
more importantly that people can help
them
to go to the market as fast as they can
and this makes the difference
the expertise of the go-to-market
and the the deer flow that comes from
different places we now open a new
uh market for one of our companies from
here in argentina
because we have investors in argentina
yeah
no no that i think i mean these this
idea of chapters and connecting the
world and understanding that
you know it's 20 20 it's not just about
the market that and the geographic
location you're sitting in and now they
were experiencing
the corona times and doing this over and
doing this virtually
and to me it's a very humbling
experience and i'm learning a lot
i want three words that describe you
i don't know
i'm curious because that's the basic
thing of being journalists
i think i'm i'm a visionary person
always and i'm a person of persons um
i think those are the three few words
what was the third one
i'm a person i'm i'm i'm i like people
personally
yeah i'm a brutal person definitely
aren't you i have to say that
uh first of all mensch and second
um no
i think when i think of you i think of
as you say you know it's not about being
aggressive or implied it's about you
know
you know who you are and you say what do
you think and and
it's not about the big flashy
presentation it's about
the val the real value that we are
creating and i think that's
that's something that i'm i'm really
learning from this experience as well
oh dead yeah thank you very much
you